in its third week russia's war on
ukraine has seen more fighting more
suffering and more attempts to find a
diplomatic way out of the violence
authorities in ukraine say rocket
attacks have destroyed an air base near
the town of vasil kiev in the kiev
region president zielinski has also
accused russia of kidnapping the mayor
of the occupied city of melitopo
officials released this footage which
they say shows him being abducted his
whereabouts remain unknown
meanwhile russian forces appear to be
closing in on the ukrainian capital
shelling has already reached the
outskirts of keefe
fire crews rushed to the scene
after a mortar struck an apartment
building on the outskirts of kiev
the artillery shelling started at around
6 30 in the morning
[Music]
there are people living in these
apartment buildings
with russia stepping up its bombardment
of ukrainian cities including the
capital it's feared more and more
civilians will be caught in the
crossfire
satellite images show russian forces
just 25 kilometers from central kiev
president velo de mierzelenski has
promised ukrainians will put up a stiff
fight in what he's calling a war for the
country's independence
we have no right to let up in the
intensity of our defense
no matter how difficult it is
we have no right to let up in the force
of our resistance the enemy is bringing
more columns into ukrainian territory
[Music]
the besieged port city of mariupo
continues to bear the full brunt of
russia's bombardment
the humanitarian situation is worsening
by the hour for hundreds of thousands
trapped without power running water or
fresh food
in the nearby southern city of malitopol
which has already been taken by russian
forces residents turned out to protest
against the alleged kidnapping of their
mayor and to demand his release
as fighting rages people in and around
kiev will be hoping and praying that
last minute diplomacy could still spare
them the worst of what has happened to
other ukrainian cities
let's get straight across to kevin speak
to dw's correspondent matthias bolinga
matias britain's defense ministry saying
russian ground forces are advancing on
kiev's city center can you tell us your
assessment of the situation
so about 25 20 25 kilometers from where
i am standing russian troops uh are
seem to be enhancing their positions
however they have been there for almost
since the beginning of the war so for
weeks so it's absolutely unclear uh why
the british are saying that they are
closing in on kiev what has happened is
that russia has brought more troops
inside this
into these positions and it seems to
have
hold some ground uh there and have taken
firmer control of these areas but it
doesn't look like they are closer to the
city center than they have been
yesterday the day before yesterday or a
week ago
what we have seen is
well this guy was just shouting slurs at
putin people here of course are um very
angry at what's happening
so and then somebody is passing by and
he's shouting glory to ukraine so you
can see it's very emotional these troops
that are there they have been standing
there for some time
and
[Music]
there was a column if you remember that
was 60 kilometers long uh uh look looked
like rolling towards kiev but didn't
move this column has dispersed and this
has led some analysts to say that
russia's troops are regrouping now
they're trying a different strategy well
thanks for that matthias um we see the
anger there on the streets from those
people who are walking past you i want
to ask about the situation in kiev
itself especially with regard to
supplies where do things stand will
people be able to hold out against a
possible russian onslaught
the question is what this russia
onslaught will look like so there are
different scenarios that are
probable and that are uh feared here one
of them would be that russia would be
able to close the ring around the
capital and then we would see something
similar to mariupol people not being
able to leave supplies not coming in i
believe that the city has of course
stocked up with supplies but you can
only get that far with these supplies
and we are also seeing that a lot of
places inside the city have been
fortified there are lots of roadblocks
etc
the other scenario is a mass bombardment
like in kharkiv where
the huge parts of the city of the
residential areas of the city are
constantly being shelled and thus a
humanitarian
crisis is is brought upon the city this
um is is another thing of course people
would be very it would be very hard for
people to to to
to live under these circumstances and to
cope with them but for now what we've
seen been seeing also is that despite
all efforts russian troops had not have
not managed to get any closer to the
city than they have been there have been
a few advances other others have been
fought back so basically it stays where
it is but with a lot more uh firepower
and
troops
seemingly coming in let's talk about the
diplomatic efforts ukrainian president
zielenski has suggested talks with
russia in jerusalem what else can you
tell us about that proposal
jerusalem has taken the initiative to
talk to both leaders jerusalem has very
good relations the actual israeli
government has very good relations to
putin's government and
there was an effort to um
to to to negotiate between the two
however so far what we are hearing is
that nothing uh of this has really
worked or that there haven't been any
results there has been the news uh that
uh israel was pressuring ukraine to
surrender this has been uh reject or
this this has been falsified by the uh
ukrainian government saying that there
had not been such a pressure and as a
reaction to these news zelensky has
suggested that israel might invite the
two parties to negotiate in jerusalem
but it's only one possible way where
people could be negotiating the problem
is what could they be negotiating
against when there is the maximum demand
from russia's that russia is still
upholding that ukraine basically give up
its army and its sovereignty and ukraine
demanding russian troops out of the
country so um there is not much to
negotiate about except and that's the
hope that this might be
advancing there have been attempts to
negotiate smaller
problems like humanitarian corridors to
release the pressure on the population
to release the relieve the humanitarian
crisis this is probably something that's
much more likely to negotiate upon uh
than any outcome of the war
okay our correspondent matias bologna
reporting for us from akiv thank you so
much and please stay safe
and i want to get across now to maria
sirichenko i've been speaking to her on
dw news over the past week after she had
to flee her home in mariupol for the
relative safety of the western ukrainian
city of levive hi maria welcome back and
thanks again for taking the time under
these terrible circumstances uh first
some of our viewers may remember that
your grandmother is still in mario pool
and the last time we spoke you'd been
unable to contact her for more than a
week
have you had any update on her situation
now
hi and thanks for having me again yes i
haven't heard anything from her
for 11 days already so
still no connection with her or with
other relatives that live in mariopol
however yesterday we managed to get some
updates from the neighbor
who uh escaped the city two days ago
and they didn't see my grandmother
personally however they shared they that
while they were there they saw the
curtains in my grandma house
raised you know every morning
so at least this piece of information
gives me and my family some hope that
she is there she is alive
so this is the only news that i get uh
from
someone in mariota during the last few
days that must be terrible to have just
that piece of information but also
encouraging um to see that sign of life
you said you've had no communication
with others in mariopol are you hearing
anything about the situation there from
others
yeah i didn't manage to reach any of my
close people however my friend's parents
called here yesterday they managed to
find some spot in the center of the city
where there was some weak mobile network
and they shared that the
city is being shelled
every hour every minute
and i heard from telegram channel you
know there are some groups so when
people
communicate and exchange some
information between them so i heard that
my neighborhood where my parents live
it was really damaged yesterday and
today and uh the bomb hit my house
where my parents have an apartment and i
have no idea whether my apartment is
still there or it's completely destroyed
so
this is terrifying
and maria you're in levive now
what is your plan from there
well i'm still here i still have no
plans to leave the country within the
nearest future and i hope that the
situation at least here will remain a
bit stable as it is now and we continue
helping our people for instance today we
were again on the railway station trying
to get some humanitarian stuff to to
kiev
and
there are a lot of people here and
everyone
wants to
take part in some volunteering
initiatives and help each other
maria we're going to leave it there
thank you again for joining us on dw
news and please take care
thank you
and the un says more than 2.5 million
refugees have fled to other countries
since the invasion of ukraine began the
majority of those people 1.5 million
according to polish border authorities
have headed to poland others have made
their way to hungary slovakia moldova
and romania more than a hundred thousand
have also entered russia
and i'm now joined by dw correspondent
brigitte shulka she joins me from poland
near the border with ukraine hi welcome
to the show thanks for joining us um
you've just been speaking to these
ukrainian refugees arriving can you tell
us a little bit about what their
journeys have been like
we heard a lot of harrowing accounts
today because the people who were
arriving here the women and children
actually fled a war zone they
experienced heavy shelling they had been
trapped in bunkers for for days during
their escape they
had often to sleep in the freezing
nights while waiting at the border
some were even shot at so
they're very relieved that they are here
now but they are still so worried about
those who they had to leave behind so
their husbands their
other family parts like parents
so they they really need sometimes to
adapt to the new situation they suddenly
in and we recorded some of their
accounts and maybe we can just listen in
all our forces through themselves
against putin
he is a criminal
he's the problem
his army used tanks to attack my
grandmother's house we prayed to god to
grant us safe passage
my child was crying all the time
because people were dying
it was very scary when the bombs hit our
town directly we lost light electricity
and water
and at five in the morning the bombs
were falling down again right in the
center of the city
they killed people the bombs killed 21
people including three children i have
nightmares when i'm thinking about it
[Music]
it's hard to wrap your head around just
how much these people have left behind
burgerta i want to ask you from where
you stand how well poland has been able
to accommodate these people arriving
i think they are really doing a very
very good job here compared to the first
day
the help is much better organized now we
just came back from the border crossing
and
there are a lot of volunteers there who
are providing food and clothes and the
people who are arriving
they are immediately registered so they
don't have to wait anymore in the cold
and they are placed on buses to be
relocated to other cities but still i
mean it's it's a huge challenge for
everybody here just to give you an
example we are here now in the city of
jerusalem and
this city has only 60 000
citizens but they are welcoming
between thirty thousand and fifty
thousand refugees every day so that that
needs a lot of resources
that's right we've heard polish
authorities saying 1.5 million people
have already arrived if they continue
arriving in poland at this pace will the
authorities there be able to manage
this will depend on how
how much
help
poland is getting from other european
countries especially if it comes to
relocating the refugees but from
what we hear here from the people there
is a strong commitment to to further
welcome the refugees the only problem is
right now
the whole relief effort is heavily
depending on volunteers and the small
communities like cherish
where we are here now
um and
we in a way we sense a growing
frustration amongst those groups because
the polish government hasn't provided
any additional help yet so there is a
little of frustration they are really
waiting to get some more funding but
to be clear this frustration is directed
towards their own government rather than
the refugees
okay dw's burger shulker thank you so
much for your reporting
let's bring you up to speed now on some
other developments in the conflict a
ukrainian woman evacuated from a mario
paul maternity hospital after a russian
airstrike has had her baby
little veronica was born in another
hospital on the city's outskirts
russia's attack on the children's and
maternity hospital on wednesday led to
widespread international condemnation
the international atomic energy agency
says power has been partially restored
to chernobyl nuclear power station the
site of the 1986 nuclear disaster
ukrainian technicians say they are
repairing the plant which was seized by
russian forces early in the war the
power cut led to fears over the safety
of the spent reactor rods stored at the
plant
u.s troops continue to be deployed to
europe adding to thousands who have
already been sent to support nato allies
following russia's invasion of ukraine
about 130 soldiers left the u.s state of
georgia the pentagon has ordered roughly
12 000 service members from u.s bases to
europe
france says russian president vladimir
putin shows no willingness to end the
war with ukraine french president
emmanuel macron and german chancellor
olaf schultz held joint telephone talks
with putin on saturday afternoon
during the 19-minute 90-minute call the
two western leaders urged putin to agree
to an immediate cease-fire in ukraine
schultz's office said he and macron
called on putin to begin the process of
finding a diplomatic solution putin
briefed macron and schultz on recent
talks between russian and ukrainian
negotiating teams
and let's dive into this with our
political correspondent thomas sparrow
he joins me now in the studio thomas can
you tell us more about what has come out
of this round of diplomacy so france and
germany have placed their hopes for a
long time already but now more than ever
on trying to find a diplomatic solution
what that specifically means is that
they want first and foremost a ceasefire
an immediate ceasefire that's something
that did come out of that
of that talk that they asked vladimir
putin for that specific ceasefire that
has to be the precondition for what was
then described as structured talks to
try and find a political solution to
this war now that is the goal but if you
judge by what french officials have been
saying after that call
turning those goals into concrete action
will be particularly difficult with
french officials stressing that from
that call it was clear that vladimir
putin did not show any willingness to
end the war in ukraine so at least we
have here the concrete goal that german
and french leaders now have turning that
into action will be another matter
altogether now they're of course not the
first leaders who've attempted to
mediate between russia and ukraine uh
how successful do you think macron
schultz are likely to be
well they have already played an
important role even before this war
let's not forget that france and germany
in various circumstances in various
crises have worked hand in hand to try
and find solutions and in particular in
the ukrainian context after the 2014
crisis france and germany did play a
very important role mediating in
trying to find a political solution to
the situation in the eastern part of
ukraine you may know the the normandy
format which then also led to the
so-called minst agreements france and
germany did play an important role there
and as such they still believe now that
they can play a very important role when
it comes to finding a diplomatic
political solution to the war but it's
important to see this from a wider
perspective it's not only germany and
france we see for example leaders in
israel also willing to play an important
role in turkey trying to play an
important diplomatic role what all this
tells us is that the international
community is particularly interested in
trying to find
diplomatic solutions to this war even
though it is particularly difficult at
the moment in fact it's not just heads
of state trying to find a solution we
have this rather unusual case where the
former german chancellor gerhard
schroeder has actually attempted to get
involved in negotiations even flying to
moscow this week
he's of course been strongly criticized
for connections to the kremlin and let's
call it these freelance mediation
attempts do you think his involvement is
the reason why chancellor schultz has
decided to get involved now no i don't
think it's the reason why chancellor
schultz is getting involved now i think
that is something that the german
government had wanted to do already in
the past to try and find a diplomatic
solution to this situation but it does
make diplomatic efforts official
diplomatic efforts more and more
difficult especially from a german
perspective because it gives the
impression to the outside world that
germany is not only
one position that is not working on a
united front that you have on the one
hand the german government and on the
other hand gerhard schroeder former
german chancellor between 1998 and 2005
who has been indeed very criticized by
his closeness to the kremlin and by his
job as a gas lobbyist for
russian energy giants and it's important
to stress that this visit by gerhart was
not coordinated with the current german
government from his perspective from
gerhard schroeder's perspective i
understand or at least i believe this
would be an attempt on his side to try
and polish his image a little bit try
and clean up that image that has been
very criticized because he has refused
so far to drop to cancel those
appointments that he has
with those energy giants from russia so
a very difficult situation all together
from the german perspective because it
makes official negotiations much more
difficult than expected our political
correspondent thomas barrow thanks so
much for joining me in the studio with
that update